[موسيقى]
لست وحدك ربما كانت تلك هي رساله زياره
الرئيس الصيني
الى روسيا الى الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
تحديدا وهو يخوض غمار حربه في اوكرانيا
الحرب التي لا يعرف احد كيف ولا متى
ستنتهي ولما ستاتي به من اصطفافات قد تضرب
بنيه النظام العالمي القائم او تخلخله
منذره بقيام اخر
وترقب الولايات المتحده ومن ورائها الغرب
الداعم لاوكرانيا بكثير من الحذر وربما
الخوف التقارب الصيني الروسي الذي سرعت
وتييرته الحرب فدفعت به الى افق
استراتيجيين هما تعبر عنه تصريحات
الرئيسيين الصيني والروسي فقد تعهد بتحقيق
تعاون شامل بين بلديهما على جميع
المستويات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه
والتكنولوجيه ومنبع الخشيه الغربيه من
العلاقه الاستراتيجيه بين الصين و هو ان
البلدين يمثلان موقفا رافضا للحيمره
الغربيه وقيمها وما يصفانه بطبيعتها
الامبرياليه وهما لا يترددان في الدعوه
الصريحه الى نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب
يضمن السلم والتعاون الدولي دونما اكراهات
الغرب من جهته لا سيما الولايات المتحده
ينظر الى البلدين خاصه الصين على انهما
خطران ماثلان بدرجات متفاوته مهددان
للنظام العالمي بقيمه الديمقراطيه هكذا
هما في التصور الاستراتيجي الامريكي
لمهددات الزعامه الامريكيه للعالم وربما
لم يقصد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن احدا
اكثر من الصين وروسيا وهو يصدر وثيقه
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكي في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي بقوله
لن نترك مستقبالنا عرضه لاهواء اولئك
الذين لا يشاركوننا رؤيتنا لعالم حر
ومنفتح ومزدهر وامن عالم حر ومزدهر وامن
هنا مقبره الصراع بين رؤيتين تغريده
السفير الامريكي في طوكيو تلخص ذلك على
افضل وجه وهو يعلق على الزياره المفاجئه
لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
بانه مصطف مع الحريه اما
فمنحاز الى مجرم
وتوفر الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا لخطاب
الحرب الغربي مثالا على ما تصنعه السلطه
المستبده بقوتها من جرائم على غرار ما
يفعل بوتين في اوكرانيا او ما تفعل الصين
باقليتها المسلمه من الايغور وبسبب من هذه
الرؤيه التي ترد الدولتين الى اصل واحد في
الاستبداد تجاهل الغرب مبادره الرئيس
الصيني لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا والدخول في
مفاوضات فقد حذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
العالم من الانخداع بالمبادره الصينيه
وطعن في اهليه الصين المنحازه الى روسيا
في ان تكون وسيطا عادلا ومعروف ان الصين
امتنعت عن التصويت على مشروع قرار فرض
عقوبات على روسيا في مجلس الامن بل ان
الصينه تتهم بانها تزود موسكو بالاسلحه
رغم ان ذلك لم يثبت كما ان الغربه ياخذ
على الرئيس الصيني ما سماه بتفهمه للوضع
الروسي وهي اشاره خفيه في التصريحات
الى المخاطر التي رتبها التوسع حلف الناتو
شرقا الى الحدود الروسيه
واياما كانت الخلافات في طبيعه السلطه بين
الغرب من جهه والصين وروسيا من جهه اخرى
فانما لم يعد خافيا هو ان مستقبل التقارب
الاستراتيجي بين الصين وروسيا سيكون محددا
اساسيا للتغيرات الجيوسياسيه التي قد
تشهدها العشريه الاولى من هذا القرن
فالصين وفق المراقبين لن تسبح بهزيمه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا مطوره
موقفها بحسب مجريات الحرب لان الهزيمه
العسكريه قد تؤدي الى انهيار نظام بوتين
بالكليه في موسكو وساعدها قد تجد الصين
نفسها الهدف الثاني في استراتيجيه الغرب
وخاصه امريكا لتصفيه او تحيد المنافسين
على قياده العالم
وكل ذلك قد يجعل في راي المراقبين التحالف
الصيني الروسيه تحالف ضروره استراتيجيه
تحتمها غريزه البقاء في عالم لم يغادر
يوما منطقه الغابه